c'est à colmar au conseil départemental
que nous avions rendez vous pour le
lancement du site
j'ai au reina ce dernier est un outil
géographique permettant de mieux
connaître le bassin rhénan il est
accessible à partir d'aujourd'hui est
plus intéressé autant les enfants que
les adultes
vous pourrez y trouver des cartes au
format pdf ou encore un géoportail
alors j'ai aurait n'a aujourd'hui pas
c'est le nouveau nom du géoportail qui a
été élaboré sur l'ensemble du rhin
supérieur et ce chez ceux géoportail
il a une vocation vraiment importante
c'est la reprise d'une cartographie
complète de notre rhin supérieur sur
différents thèmes ya une grande
thématique qui est qu'ils aient
développé notamment la route laissée que
là cela la sécurité les universités le
monde économique le monde universitaire
beaucoup d'allemands et de suisse était
présent au lancement de ce nouveau
portail le site proposera lui des cartes
bilingue c'est tout le rhin supérieur le
rhin supérieur c de l'alsace c'est le
pays de bade donc toute la zone du
bade-würtemberg qui jouxte le rhin et la
suisse du nord-ouest c'est ce leurre
argovie canton de bâle-ville
bâle-campagne et jura suisse alors j'ai
au reina qui s'appelait avant système
d'information géographique de la
conférence du rhin supérieur puisque
l'outil rattaché à la conférence du rhin
supérieur l'idée est née en 2000 donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes en 2010 est donc
ça fait
plus d'une dizaine d'années que l'outil
existe et qui les exploitent et qu'il
est élargie géo reina bénéficie d'un
financement de 360 milles euros sur
trois ans pour agrandir une base de
données déjà bien complète